so with the economy tanking can you
please give us some Insider uh
Congressional trading tips please so
that's enough by the way another area
where the populist right and populists
left should work together I do not
believe that members of Congress should
trade individual stocks we have
information that other people do not and
we have the ability to impact
how various companies do based on the
types of programs we authorize or uh or
that we pull and so it's just crazy to
me that that was ever allowed and uh
you're talking about you know big Tech
bills and like potentially breaking up
Facebook and just imagine if you're
about to even vote on that and then you
go and you know put option and get put
options that's not a hypothetical that
happened I mean we had bills that were
moving through the Judiciary Committee
that passed out of the Judiciary
Committee that broke up big Tech and we
were all getting ready for them to come
to the floor and on the dip Paul Pelosi
bought a bunch of those stocks wow and
then guess what guess what Tim they
never [ __ ] came to the floor